dude where's my pool
look at that guys send it so by darcy
fitch
her ring doorbell caught this inflatable
pool
flying out about denise and i talked
about this we see that flying
trampolines all the time
but when have we ever seen a flying pool
right so we put this posted this on
social media so please
share it with your friends and family
that's pretty cool shot there thank you
darcy for sending that to us and
we love your videos and your pictures
just sent to us we love showing them on
tv so
send them our way live look outside
right now
we do have high base thunderstorms and
showers out there and we're also seeing
clouds out there too i really think if
we had fewer clouds
and just pure sunshine it really would
have been hotter i really believe that
air quality in a moderate category those
clouds are mixed in with some smoke
pivoting in from arizona where we
currently have some wildfires burning so
moderate air quality right now unhealthy
as far as the ozone goes
111 for sky canyon in centennial hills
at this hour
110 for spring valley 112 for north las
vegas 114
for sunrise manor and whitney rancher
114 as well 109
mountains edge and rhodes ranch 114 also
for
green valley 111 henderson and 110 for
southern highlands and we will always
switch up your neighborhoods for you so
nobody is left out
106 for indian springs 108 for prop and
mesquite up there northeast clark 114
laughlin 118 in death valley 124 for you
you broke a record today
with your high at 128. there's the high
responsible for the clouds responsible
for the heat and responsible for some
showers
that we're seeing mainly arizona right
now and also into southeast california
as they move their way around that high
coming up towards us they dissipate and
die
out and we're talking thunderstorms
we're not talking the big downpours okay
because it's so dry out there
we're talking the rain comes down hits
that drier air
dissipates and gives us big outflow
winds that's mainly we're going to see
and also some lightning strikes along
with it so that fire danger is high
as well your weekend forecast friday 113
is what we're calling for coming close
to that record high everyone's
loving this right for the hamburgers 114
for saturday
coming or actually tying that record on
saturday i don't think we're going to
tie that record on sunday but it's still
being 111 for
all the dads out there overnight low
will be close to 90 degrees again
look at the numbers for your overnight
low that'll be another record low
and outside the valley death valley will
be at 99 for the overnight temperature
89 overnight another record will be set
tomorrow probably not going to reach the
record but we'll come close
113 the record high is 115 for it also
back in 1940
the heat warning like we said extended
all the way through sunday i'll stop by
a step out of the way here so you can
see
look at that finally dropping to 102
degrees
next week i'll take it chris will send
it over to you buddy